hey guys welcome back to another video
by simply learn this is a cortland full
course video in which we will be
learning about all the important
concepts and topics that we need to
understand in order to grasp the course
in programming language
one by one we will go through each and
every topic of the scotland full course
and learn them with the help of hands-on
examples
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and
press the bell icon to never miss an
update
so
we will start by understanding what is
kotlin or introduction to kotlin then we
will understand few concepts of kotlin
language by going through kotlin
tutorial for beginners
after that we will understand concepts
like if else
loops in kotlin and cotton functions
then we will understand kotlin
multi-platform and kotlin co routines
and at last we will cover cortland
jetpack tutorial
so let's go ahead
with the first topic which is what is
kotlin or introduction to kotlin
so why kotlin
kotlin is one of the fastest growing and
widely used programming language
in may 2017
google announced it as an official
language for developing android
applications
after this announcement the jobs for
kotlin increased in large numbers
since then the job openings for kotlin
gets doubled every three months as per
dice
it is very easy and friendly language
also it is quite easy to maintain and
debug this language
which is why it is a good language to
start with
kotlin has a bright future as it is
being widely used for android
development companies like google
netflix pinterest are some of the
companies using kotlin
so being a kotlin developer will boost
up your career growth
now coming to what is scotland
kotlin is an open source statically
typed language designed by jetbrains
it has both the features of
object-oriented programming and
functional programming
kotlin is interoperable with java that
means both the languages can share and
use the information
and just like java compiler the kotlin
compiler also generates the byte code
which can run on jvm
also we can say kotlin is kind of java
with some added features
even the java libraries can also be used
in kotlin project although java is a
really cool language the developers of
kotlin focused
more on simplifying the code and
increasing the transparency
now let's learn some history of the
scotland language
the development of the kotlin language
was announced in the year 2011.
in 2012 the first web demo of kotlin was
released along with the new logo and
became an open source
then in 2014
kotlin lang.org was released along with
some features to increase the
interoperability with java
in the year 2015 some new features were
added like the companion objects
multiple constructor etc
after a quite long development process
kotlin 1.0 version was released in
february 2016.
it was developed by jetbrains in russia
the developers of jetbrains were fed up
with the repetitive code so they wanted
a much modern language
but the problem was most of their code
was already written in java and
switching to some other language would
create a bigger headache for them
so the team decided to create a language
which is compatible with java and with
all the features they wanted
so then they created the kotlin language
in the year 2017 google announced the
first class support for kotlin on
android
later kotlin 1.2 was released with
features like sharing code between jvm
and javascript
after that
various versions were released like
kotlin 1.3 in 2018
kotlin 1.4 in 2020 kotlin 1.5 in 2021
etc
now
moving on to features of kotlin language
the first feature is
kotlin language can be used on multiple
platforms which reduces the time that is
spent on writing and maintaining the
code on different platforms kotlin
doesn't depend on virtual machine on the
target platform
next is kotlin has some modern features
like null safety which is a feature to
reduce the problems associated with the
null references
then the lambda function which is an
anonymous function
and the smart casts which are used to
track conditions inside the expression
next is
in kotlin language there are many
extensions
which allows us to add the functionality
without inheriting from the class or any
decorative pattern
this feature makes the code easy to
maintain and read
now coming to another feature of kotlin
which is
in kotlin functions can be passed as
parameters to the function
that means function act as a variable
and just like the variable it can also
be passed
it is also known as higher order
function its functionality is to do two
things
first to take the functions as
parameters and second to return a
function
next feature is kotlin is compatible
with java
it is fully interoperable with java and
you can convert the java file to the
kotlin file with just a script
also it works on jvm and java libraries
work fine on kotlin
next is
in kotlin there is a data class
a data class is that class which doesn't
perform any operation
and only contains state
the advantage of this class is that it
provides self-generated code and avoids
the implementation of methods within the
class
now
coming to uses of kotlin
kotlin is used in web development it is
compatible with java and also
much easier to work with
also kotlin works fine with spring and
some other frameworks
which makes it an easy replacement of
java when it comes to web development
next is
kotlin is used in data science as well
because of its features like null safety
statically typed maintainable code and
also being a language which runs on jvm
makes kotlin a good choice for working
with the data
next is it is used for android
development
after google has announced kotlin as the
first class language the user's interest
in kotlin language elevated to a great
extent which resulted in creating a
large community of android developers
going for kotlin
this language allows the developers to
write more expressive and concise code
and its interoperability with java is
one of the main attraction to choose
this language
with google statement not only the
android developers but also the app
development companies are opting the
kotlin language
similar to these users there are many
more uses to the kotlin language
but now
let's move on to its applications
so we'll start with google
google widely uses the kotlin language
not only they have declared it as the
first class programming but they also
use it in their production code
google also implemented kotlin in more
than 60 applications
such as google home
google maps google drive google pay
google sheets etc
similarly airbnb which is an american
company that operates online marketplace
for lodging and home stays to vacation
rentals also uses kotlin language for
their android frameworks mvrx for a
seamless experience
other companies like zometo which is
india's largest food delivery company
also uses kotlin for the android app
which has helped them to reduce the
lines of code and made the code a lot
more concise
next is netflix
netflix is world's leading streaming
service also use the kotlin language to
rebuild their ui player for the android
app of netflix
next is uber
the american mobility company uber that
provides services like food delivery
ride healing package delivery couriers
etc uses kotlin language because of its
popularity for android development and
its interoperability with java
so these were some popular companies
that uses the kotlin language
similar to these companies there are
many more companies like pinterest
tinder slack etc that uses this language
now let's have a look at what we have
learnt so far
in this video we spoke about why kotlin
language what exactly kotlin is then
history of kotlin language and some of
the features and uses of kotlin language
and at last we have covered the
companies that uses cotton language
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
kotlin is a general purpose statically
typed programming language developed and
released by jetbrains in 2016.
in 2011 jetbrains revealed the kotlin
project which is a new language for jvm
and later in february 2016 its first
version kotlin 1.0 was released
this language is concise and more
expressive than java
it is fully interoperable with java and
it is also said that kotlin language is
made by extracting all the good parts of
different programming languages like
scala javascript java c-sharp etc
google also announced kotlin as the
first class language for android
development
so it is now an official language for
the development of android and is being
opted by many organizations across the
globe
now let's move on to our next topic
which is variables in kotlin
there are two types of variables in
kotlin
which are
where and well
first where
the where variables are mutable
which means their value can be
reassigned
then there is val
the val variables are immutable which
means their value cannot be reassigned
or changed or modified
as you can see in the example where is
the type of the variable name and the
value raj is assigned to it
after that
the value is reassigned as said
so after printing it will display set
because where is mutable type and its
value can be reassigned
on the other hand val is the variable
whose value cannot be reassigned
which means it is immutable
as we can see in the example on printing
the value of the name variable
it is showing an error because we tried
to change or reassign the value from raj
to sid
and because it is a val type variable
the value is not going to change
kotlin
is smart enough to understand which is
string and which is an integer
so it is not necessary to specify the
type
like in this example
name is the string and roll number is
the integer
but we haven't specified their type and
still there is no error
however it is possible to specify the
type if you want
now coming to next topic which is string
templates
a string can be defined as a collection
of characters enclosed in double quotes
the string templates allows us to
include the expressions variable
references inside the string
the references in a string start with
the dollar sign
to print the string
we need to add the dollar sign before
the string name
we can easily add the variables in the
string instead of concatenating them
for example here name one and name two
are two strings and we can include them
together
within the same sentence while printing
like both
dollar sign name one and dollar sign
name to our best friends
it will display the value of string
within the sentence
we can also print the expression like we
did while printing the second sentence
dot to uppercase
dot upper case is an expression and in
kotlin expressions start with the dollar
sign
and are enclosed in the curly brackets
as you can see
so as we have understood about the
string templates let's move on to if
else and when statements
if is used with a condition
if that condition is true
then the block of code executes and if
the condition is not true or false then
the else block executes
now in quarterly language the if-else
statements can also be used as
expressions that means they can return a
value while using if else as an
expression it is mandatory to use the
else branch
here in the example we can see if a is
greater than b is the expression and the
value of that expression is assigned to
the variable named great
now
which so ever is greater among them
that will be assigned to it and is then
printed
now coming to when statements
when statements in kotlin is similar to
switch statement in java
when statement is used to select one
code block from the multiple code blocks
based on a conditional expression
the code block which satisfy the
condition is executed
for example as you can see the value 4
is assigned to the variable tab
now whichever value matches with the
value of tab
that particular code block will execute
in this case there are no code blocks
but single line branches
the branch value that matches with the
value of tap
that particular branch will execute
like wrap will execute
which is then stored in the order
variable
which is then printed
now
let's move on to areas in kotlin
arrays are generally used to store
multiple values in contiguous memory
location in a single variable
in kotlin language to create an array
you have to use the address of function
and then
write the elements inside the bracket
for example here name is the array name
and sid robbie max john are the elements
of the array
in order to print the elements of the
array you can use loops
for example here we are using for loop
in this for loop n is the variable
names is the array name
and one by one it will print every
element of the array
now
as we have understood about arrays
now let's understand about loops
loops are used to iterate through the
different parts of program
for example arrays
ranges several times
it is a set of instructions which keeps
on repeating until a certain condition
is met
it is generally used while working with
arrays
in kotlin language the for loop is bit
different to that in java
in this for loop we use a variable in
operator and the array name to display
the elements of the array for example as
you can see in the example
there is an
array with elements 4 2 5 12 7 and using
the for loop we are displaying the
elements of the array inside the for
loop
here n is the variable
n is the operator and numbers is the
array name
loops are also used to iterate through
the ranges
which we will discuss later
now let's understand why loop and do
while loop
both these loops are similar to the
loops in java
the function of the while loop
is it checks the condition and executes
through the block of code as long as the
specified condition is true
and the do while loop executes the do
block once before checking if the
condition is true
which means the loop will execute at
least once even if the condition is not
true
oh as we have understood about loops in
kotlin so now let's move on to our next
topic which is null safety
so null safety is a feature in kotlin
language that solves the problem of null
pointer exception
if you have worked on other languages
including java then you must have an
idea of null pointer exception
in cotton language you can easily create
null type variable
to create a null type variable or string
which can hold a null value we can
simply define them by putting the
question mark at the end
as you can see in the example
name is the variable name and string is
the type and after string there is a
question mark which means that this
variable is of null type
by default all the variables are not
null in kotlin
but you can create one by putting a
question mark with them
now moving on to the next topic which is
ranges
now ranges can be defined as an interval
from start to end
expressions are created with double dot
operator and an in operator here in the
example 0 is the starting point and 7 is
the ending point in between them there
is operator double dot operator which
means that the loop will iterate from 0
to 7.
similarly we can also print the range
with gaps like in the example
i in 0 to 10
step 2
means that it will print from 0 to 10
the gap of 2 digits like 0 2
4 6 8 10
range can also be used in decrement
manner for example i in 7 down to 2
means the loop will iterate from 7 to 2
in a decreasing order
now
let's move on to the next topic which is
kotlin functions
functions are also known as methods
they are the block of code which runs
whenever it is invoked
in kotlin language functions are defined
with the fun keyword
after that the name of the function and
parenthesis
are written
if the parentheses are empty it means
function doesn't accept any arguments
in function with parameters the
parameters are specified inside the
parenthesis
the type of parameter is specified after
the name of the parameter
so we can see in the example fun is the
name of the function
num1 num2 are the parameters name
int is the type of the parameters
then after that the colon there is
another int data type
which is the return type that means it
is the data type of the value which is
returned
so these were some important topics of
kotlin language
now let's go to the code editor
and do some practical implementations
so this is our intellij idea here we
will do some examples of cotton language
so let's go ahead
first of all we'll create the kotlin
file
so let's name it as example one
so first we'll do an example of string
template
in which we'll have a look
that how to create those strings and how
can we use some expressions with them
so let's start
so fun is the keyword for function
now main function
now inside this main function
we'll write
well
this is immutable as we know
code is the name of the variable
now let's say
code is
cipher
in kotlin language you don't need to put
the semicolon in the end as it is not
necessary you can do it but it is not
necessary to do that
all right now
after that let's say you want to print
this
we'll write
the code is
dollar sign
code so this is how we can print
this string
and
let's see that if it works or not first
of all we'll have to save it
so we'll do save all
and now we'll go to run
now here we will
run run and select example one
all right
as you can see the code is cipher
it is getting printed
now let's say
we want to use some expression with it
right
the code is
let's say we want to write the code in
capital letters we'll write the code is
dollar sign and then the curly brackets
and inside the curly brackets we'll
write code
dot
upper case
yes uppercase
now with
brackets
now after that
you want to put the semicolon it is your
choice otherwise it is not required
so now let's save it again
evolve and now
let's try to run it
as you can see the code is cipher the
first one the code is
in capital letters cipher
so this is how we can do it and we can
also merge
the strings we don't need to concatenate
them
so we can do like this the code is this
and
right
now let's try to run it again
so here what we are doing is we are
merging the uppercase and lowercase
here we can see the code is cipher and
cipher
so this is how we can
concatenate both the strings easily so
this is one of the example of string
template
now let's do another example of
if else statements as expressions
let's go ahead
right now we'll create
main class fun main
and inside this main function
first of all we'll create two variables
that is marks one
of well type and let's assign it value
87
then another variable marks2
and we'll assign it as
let's say 82
here we are using if else as expressions
so what we'll do is
we'll make a variable result and we'll
store the value of if or else in that
particular result and then we'll display
that particular variable and let's say
that variable is
result
here we will use if else as expressions
so
val result equals if
max 1
is greater than
max 2
then
in the bracket
write
marks one
equals this is for the printing purpose
dollar sign
1
is the greater
among both
let's write
is greater
than
max 2.
variable marks
2
all right
now similarly we will do for else as
well
write else
now similarly we'll write
max2
equals
marks2 variable
is the
is greater
than
marks one
all right so after that we'll print the
variable
result because the result is getting
stored in this variable result
so whichever is greater will get stored
over here and then we will print this
variable
println
and we'll write
result
all right
now it's done and i think we have
to run this one
save it and let's try to run
example 2
hope it works
as you can see
marks 187 is greater than marks
282. as
max 1 is 87 and max 2 is 82
so marks one is greater so that is why
if block is getting printed
now
let's do an example of when statement
let's create a new file
go to new
this
kotlin file
now let's name it example three
all right so this is example three
now let's start with the one example
function main
inside this will create a variable named
coupon so let's say the variable is
where
coupon and let's assign it a value
5
all right now
the when statement works as switch
statements
it is used to select one code block or
one code branch out of many code blocks
or code branches based on the
conditional expression
which so ever code branch matches with
the condition
that particular code branch will execute
all right so
let's start with it
we'll use when keyword
and let's say
open is the
name of the variable and the value of
coupon is 5 as we can see as we have
already declared that
now
inside when
the first branch would be so this is how
you can create a first branch
and if there are multiple lines then you
have to use the brackets
all right so here we will print
here is your
coffee
all right so first message is this
the second message would be like
forgot to enter d
yeah
so the second message let's say here is
your t we will write
over here is
your t
so in the third branch
we'll write
here is your green tea
the fourth branch you will write
here is your juice
and in the fifth line or the fifth
branch
we will write here is your water
so
this is how we can create this we can
also create a default value
for that we have to use the else
statement
write else
right invalid
input
all right so this is how we are doing it
and so the value of coupon is five
and
whichever values among these like 1 2 3
4 5 5 obviously will match it
that particular
statement or
line will be printed
so let's save this one
and let's try to run it
so there's an error as you can see so
for that
we have to use the arrow operator
instead of this bracket
so let's do that
so now if any value other than these
five values is there in this variable
then this
default message will be printed that is
invalid input
so now let's save it
again
and now
run it
as you can see here is your water as the
value was five let's say the value is
six
it must show the invalid and input as
there is there are only five values
so now let's try to run this and let's
check
if it is working fine or not
as you can see invalid input
as we have entered six over here
which is not in this
one two three four five so that is why
it is printing invalid input
now let's do an example of array
let's create a new file
portland file now let's name it example
4
all right
now the main function
right now inside this function first of
all we will create an array
so how we will do that
well
let's say the name of the function is
arr1
equals
array
off
as we have discussed already array of
now the number of elements
like 2
4
6
8
12.
these are the elements of array1
now similarly we will create an array2
write
array
array off
of the elements
1
3
5 7
9 11.
all right now
now here we will use
a set function
so if we want to set a particular
element at a particular position then
we'll use set and if we want to display
a particular element of the array then
we'll use get
so first of all we'll understand set
so
array1 dot
set
so first here we will write the position
let's say one is the position and at one
position we want to set 5 as an element
so this is the syntax for it
and let's say for array 2
array 2 dot set now here we want to set
at zeroth position
and we want to set
two element
so first is the position and second is
the element
that we want to set at that position
all right
now
[Music]
now we'll see the get
function
so
get is used to display the particular
element of an array so let's say array1
dot get
let's say i want to print the fifth
element
that is 14th in array one case
so i'll do this
similarly for array two
and in array two case i want to print
this
fourth element
that is nine
now
after that we'll use println
so that the result come out vertically
all right now if we want to print each
and every element of an array so this is
how
we can do it
for
element in
arr1 here element is the variable
array1 is the name of the array
and one by one it will print
all the elements so here we will write
element
yeah it's done
let's save it now
and now let's run it
as we can see
fourteen and nine so as we know here we
have set
five at one position at first position
so zero one so at place of four there is
five now
and here at zeroth position that is at
one position there is two
so first of all here we have
printed this get five
so at
array one position at fifth position
zero one two three four five there is
fourteen so that is why it is patenting
fourteen
in array two at fourth position there is
nine so here it is printing nine
after that
here we are printing all the elements of
the array so as we can see at the first
position we have set five instead of
four
here we are doing that so that is why
here we can see 2 5 not 4 then 6 8 12
14.
similarly as you can see at 0th position
in array 2 that is here we have set 2
so we can see
instead of 1 there is 2 3 5 7 9 and then
11.
so this is how we can
add some elements at a particular
position and print those elements and
print the array as well
so now let's do another example
right so we'll write function main
now inside this we will create an array
well arr1
now in kotlin you can create an array
having the integer elements and
character elements or string elements as
well in a same array
so i'll show you that
array of
so first we'll write down the integer
elements let's say 2 4
6
and then
the string elements
let's say
it
and then 10.
so this is our array
within the same area there are integer
elements and string elements
all right
now using for loop
we will try to print this
element in
array one dot
here dot indices means if we want to the
print the index of each of these
elements
let's say if we just want to print the
elements so we'll not use this
we'll simply
print ln
and then we'll do is
array one
this is just for printing purpose
element
then
all right
so now let's save it
let's run it
as you can see
2 4 6 8 10 it is printing without any
error so we can easily do that
in kotlin
and these are the
indexes for the index if we want to
print the index of these elements we'll
do is dot
indices
now let's save it again
and run it
as you can see area of one with zero
index zero one two three four
the index is correct but the elements
are not
so i think this yeah we forgot to write
array of
in the bracket
now
let's save it again
now let's again try to run this
again let's try to run this
all right as you can see
array with index numbers will print 2 4
6
8 10
so
not only the integer elements are
getting printed but also the string
elements are also getting printed along
with the index number
because of this dot indices we are also
able
to print the index of array elements
so these were some examples of kotlin
language you can try some more examples
on it the more you'll practice the more
you'll get to know about this language
conditionals in kotlin
conditional expression refers to a
situation that may happen or exist if a
specific condition is met
for example there's a statement like we
can sit on the front benches if we
reached before the given time
now here the conditional statement is
if we reached before the given time
and the main clause is we can sit on the
front benches
so here sitting on the front bench which
is a main clause is dependent on
if they reach before the time
so now
there are some conditionals in kotlin
like if else and else if
so let's have a look at that first is if
statement
if is used when a block of code must be
executed based on the condition to be
true
second is else statement else is used
when a block of code must be executed if
the same condition is false
third is elseif statement
elsif is used to specify a new condition
if the previous condition is false
we will understand them in detail
now moving on to different types of
if-else expressions
first is if expression second is if else
expression third is
if else if letter expression and fourth
is nested if expression
now
let's understand the if expression first
if expression is a conditional statement
which checks if a particular condition
is satisfied
the condition is specified inside the if
brackets and it checks if it met the
condition or not
if they met the condition then the block
will execute otherwise not
as we can see there is a statement then
there is if condition
if the condition is satisfied that is if
it is true
then only the if code will execute
otherwise
if
it is false then control will exit
now moving on to if else expression
the if else expression has two blocks of
statements the if block executes if the
condition is true and if the condition
is false then the else block executes
the if else is similar to if expression
the only difference is
it has one extra block known as else
lock
a simple example of if else is a
conversation between a father and a son
the father says if you scored more than
85 percent then i will buy you a car
but if you scored between 75 to 85
percent then i will buy you a bike here
i will buy you a car is the code written
inside the if block
and i will buy you a bike
is a code written inside the else block
so when
the sun
scores 85 percent then his father
buy him a car
but if he scores between 75-25 range
then he will get the bike
now
moving on to if else if ladder
expression
kotlin if else if condition is used when
there are multiple conditions to be
checked
in this expression first the if
expression is checked if it's true
then it executes the if block otherwise
it moves to the other else if conditions
if none of the condition turns out to be
true then it executes the last final
else expression
to understand it let's have a look at
this example
according to this example if a student
scores marks between 80 and 105
then the cutoff is not cleared but he or
she can sit for the second examination
if the marks code is between 105 and 130
then the cutoff is cleared
if the marks scored between 130 and 180
then the cutoff is cleared and also
there will be no feet
and else cut off not cleared
so by this example we understood
that there are multiple conditions
and each condition has a specific
criteria
if the marks of the student is fit in
that criteria then that specific block
gets executed
now
moving on to the nested if expression
in kotlin nested if expression there are
if statements inside another if
statement
first the if statement is checked if it
is true then the nested if condition is
checked
if the conditions turns out to be false
then it will move to the else expression
in this example it checks for true in
condition 1
then checks for true in condition 2.
if condition 2 evaluates to true
statement 1 that is even number is
executed
otherwise statement 2 that is odd number
is executed
similarly if condition 1 evaluates to
false
then else block executes and the
statements
negative number is printed
so as we have understood all of these
expressions
so now let's do its practical
implementation
so this is our code editor
that is intellij idea so here we will be
doing some examples of kotlin if else so
let's start with the first example of if
else expression
so we'll write
function main
and inside this function we'll create
a
marks let's say the marks of the test
so we have named it test marks
now
let's say he scored 78 he or she scored
78 now we'll use if condition
and we'll write the condition
that if text marks
is let's say less than 75
then we will print you didn't qualify
the test
so we'll write
and
qualified the test
so basically to qualify a test you have
to score more than 75
so in else block
will write
print ln
will write you qualified the test
basically
if you have scored less than 75 marks
you are not qualified but if you have
scored more than 75
then you have qualified the test
here we have used the basic if else
expression
here the test marks is the variable
that we have set let's say 78
and if we have changed it like
less than 75 let's say 70 then it will
get printed you didn't qualify the test
but as we have
set the value of test marks as 78
so it means
you qualified the test will print
it's a simple example let's try to run
this
so as you can see you qualified the test
is printed
so as we know that the marks is 78 so it
is printing you qualify the test
and if we have let's say
max is 17 now again let's try to print
it
now it will print
you didn't qualify the test
as you can see
it is printing you didn't qualify the
test
now
let's have a look at an example of
nested if
so now create a new file
here we have to change the name of this
file
all right
so in this example again we'll write
function main
inside this function will create a
variable
us say the name of the variable is num
and we'll assign it 50.
now we'll set a condition if the value
of num
is let's say less than 100
then we'll print
number is less than 100 first of all
we'll print that
now if num
is equal to 50
this is the if condition inside the
first if condition this is the first if
condition this is the if condition
inside this if condition so it's a
nested if
now here we'll print
that
number equal to 50.
now inside this if condition again will
write an if condition saying that if
number is let's say greater than
40
then we'll print number is greater than
40.
basically we are printing
the condition
all right so this is the
code
now
first if condition then there is nested
if condition then there is another
nested if condition first condition says
if the number is less than 100 then it
will print number is less than 100 if it
is equal to 50 then it will print number
equal to 50 if it is greater than 40
then we'll print the number is greater
than 40.
so now let's try to run this program
so as we can see number is less than 100
first it is printing after that number
equal to 50
then the number is greater than 40.
so as we know the number is 50 that is
why all the three
statements are printed
now let's say if we change this number
like let's say the number is 45
if the number is 45 then number is less
than 100 is printed
and this sentence that is the number is
greater than 100 is printed and not
number equal to 50 because
to print this
number equal to 50 sentence the number
must be equal to 50.
now let's try to run this again
so as you can see number is less than
100 is only getting printed because as
we can see here
to
get inside this if condition the number
must be 50
as the number is not 50 but 45 so it is
not getting inside this if condition
so that is why this condition is also
not getting checked so that is why only
number is less than 100 is getting
printed
so this is an example of nested if
expression now let's do an example of
if else if letter expression
let's name it if else three
all right so now
here we will do an example of if else if
letter expression where we will
give grades to the student based on
their marks
so let's start
function main
inside this we'll create a variable
let's say well score
and assign it a value
so this value is the marks of the score
or you can say
the score is 76
now
we'll create a variable
whose type is
string
now
after that
we will have to assign this grade
so basically we are assigning the value
of if else if letter expression to this
variable grade
so this is how we do it
if
score variable
is greater than equal to 90
that is if the score is greater than 90
then we'll simply print
your grade is a plus
so yeah
here we'll do it
it is a plus
now if a student scores more than 90
then his grade is a plus
now
he will write
else if
so inside the elsif there is a condition
we can write the condition inside the
elseif as we know
4 is greater than equal to let's say
80
then we'll print
your grade is a plus
your grade is a not a plus
now after that
another else if if the score is greater
than equal to
70. then the grade is
you will write your grade
is
b plus
let's see if the score is greater than
60 similarly
write your grade as
e
you can do same for all of these we can
just copy paste it
so this one is 60 then let's make here
50 and the grade would be
c
e plus
now here would be let's say 40.
we'll do it 40 and the gate would be
c
now after that 35
let's make it 35
your grade is
[Music]
or a d
now
in else block will simply write
that is your grade is f that is if you
scored below 35
your grade is f that is your fail
so you must score more than 35 to pass
the exam
all right now after that we can print
this great variable
and let's try to run this
so as you can see your grade is b plus
it's getting printed and i think
by mistake
there is n in between
here it is
that is why it is printing in here
so our score was 76 so that is why it is
again taking printed your gate is b plus
so this expression is used when there is
a need of multiple conditions
like in this case we have
we had the need of multiple expressions
like
one condition score must be greater than
90 then only the score will be a plus
then score must be greater than 70 score
must be greater than 60 similarly for
every statement that is to be printed
there must be a specific condition
and in this type of case we use if else
if letter expression
so these were few examples of if-else
expressions
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
are used to repeatedly execute a series
of statements until a certain condition
is met
typically a process is carried out such
as retrieving and altering data
and then a condition is verified such as
whether a counter has reached a
specified value
if it hasn't the next instruction in the
sequence is a command to go back to the
first instruction in the sequence and
repeat it
so until a specified or given condition
is true or the loop is broken with the
break statement
a series of statements are going to
execute
there are various types of loops in
kotlin like for loops for each loop
for loop with ranges
while loop and do while loop
so let's go ahead and understand these
loops
now we'll start with for loop in
kotlin a for loop is a conditional
iterative statement that checks for a
specific condition
and then
constantly executes a block of code as
long as those criterias are met
the for loop differs from other looping
statements in that it provides an
explicit loop counter that allows the
loop's body to know the exact sequence
of each iteration
the for loop is used in kotlin to
traverse over ranges arrays and maps
as we can see in the diagram first there
is an initial statement then there is a
condition and if that condition
evaluates to be true then the statement
inside the loop body are executed and
updated the updation can be incremental
or decremental
then again the condition is checked if
it's true then the same process will get
repeated and if the condition is not
satisfied then the control jumps out of
the loop
this complete process will keep on
repeating until the condition evaluates
to be false
now
let's understand for loop with the help
of an example
so this is our code editor intellij idea
here we will be doing an example of for
loop
in which we will print the odd and even
elements from an array
so here we will use a for loop and if
else condition
so let's start
first of all we'll
make the main function
function main
inside this function
let's declare an array
val num
num is the name of the array and the
array of function
inside this
we'll mention the elements of the array
let's say 7
21
then let's say 23
these are the elements of the array
now after this we will simply
print a message let's say
like the odd and even numbers in the
list are as follows and then we will
apply the logic
right
the
odd
numbers
are as follows
right
now we'll use for loop
now inside this
for loop item will be the name of the
variable that will store the
variables or elements of the num array
one by one so num is the name of the
array and in between there will be in
operator
so one by one each element of the array
will be stored in item and now
we'll use
if condition
now we have to print even and odd
numbers the logic is simple we'll write
if item
and percent sign
divided by two
if the
remainder is equals to 0
then it means it is an even number so
any even number on when it is divided by
2 it will give 0 as a remainder
so if it will give 0 as the remainder
then we will print
even number
then here we'll write item
that particular element will be printed
all right now in else block
we'll do
println
and here we will write
odd number
here again we'll write
plus
item so all right
i think our code is done and
we can
run it
let's try to run this one
so as we can see even numbers and odd
numbers are getting printed
so 16 is an even number 2 is an even
number
all numbers 11 17
28 even number or number 39 and even
number 10
so i think all the elements are getting
covered
here we go 7 21 odd number
so yeah so this is how you can use for
loop and here we also have used if and
else statements
now let's understand
for each loop
for each method in kotlin allows you to
access elements in a collection or list
and perform actions on them
we can achieve the same thing using the
for loop but several for loops would
quickly make your code unreadable
as we can see in this example there is a
list name my list
and like in arrays we use array of
function similarly in list we use list
of function
the elements of the list are in winter
is and coming so there are three
elements first is winter then is then
coming
so to print each element of the list we
will use for each loop
as we can see here we have used my list
dot for each
that is the for each loop and then we
will print the iterator to print all the
elements of the array
now let's do an example on for each loop
to understand it better
so again we are back in our code editor
here we will be doing an example of
for each loop
so this example would be a simple
example function main
and inside this function
we will create a list
let's say
where
a list let's name it a list
okay so
after that
we'll use list of function
and
also let's mention the
data type
all right so now inside this
list we will mention the elements let's
say 110 and
265 and let's say 315.
so these are random elements
all right now we will have to create a
variable sum and initialize it with zero
now using this list b
sorry a list
that is the name of the list we will use
a for each loop to iterate through each
element of of the list
we'll use for each
e must be capital
after that
right for each
and now we will use
this
sum variable
to do a simple
sum of each element of the list
sum plus
here i t so i t will be storing each
element one by one it will some with the
help of some it will add each element to
one another
so initially sum is zero when 110 is
added then 265 is added to 110 then 315
282 both of them
so all right now all we need to do is to
print this we'll write print talents sum
so here we go now i think we can
try to run this one
although it is showing an error but
let's try to run this
so as i thought
i think we have to write the correct way
only
this is
the right syntax of for each loop and
yeah so now let's try to run it
as you can see 690 is getting printed
so we have to use forage bracket with
for each
only and we can't we can't enter put
space
with it so yeah so this is the syntax of
it
now let's move on to the next loop which
is for loop with ranges
a range is a set of values that fall
within a specified lower and upper limit
and the values can be numbers characters
or objects
ranges might be incremental or
decremental
but the difference between two values is
always one
as we can see in the example inside the
for loop num in one two eight
here dot dot is the operator it means
all the numbers from 1 to 8 range will
be printed
also we can use a step function to print
the elements with a gap
and we also have to mention the gap like
step 2
there are more library functions that
build ranges that aren't covered by the
double dot operator
for example down 2 creates a range that
counts down
while range 2 creates a range that
advances to a certain value
now as we have understood ranges now
let's understand while loop
while loops are used to repeatedly cycle
a block of code as long as the specified
condition returns true
the condition is verified first and if
it is true the blocks code is run
every time it enters the block the
condition is checked and as a result the
code will keep running until the
condition is met
once the loop starts the condition is
checked if that condition is satisfied
then the set of instructions are
executed and if the conditions are not
satisfied then the control jumps out of
the loop
this complete process will keep on
repeating and executing unless the
condition evaluates to be false
now let's understand while loop with the
help of an example
now here we will be doing an example of
while loop
so here we will use an array
and we will create elements of the array
like positive and negative
then using the while loop we will print
the positive numbers and the negative
numbers separately
so let's start
first of all we'll create the main
function
and inside this main function we'll
create an array let's say arr is the
name of the array
and here we are using the array of
function
inside this function we'll
write down the elements like 50 to any
random elements
minus 77 we have to write some
negative elements as well
minus 67 let's say and
minus 20
all right after that we'll
create a variable let's say i and assign
it to
initialize it with 0. so here we are
initializing it
now
within the while loop
we will write
i less than
arr dot size that the array size
so it means
this loop will keep on iterating
till the size of the array is greater
than zero
and when it becomes zero the loop will
break or the control jumps out of the
loop
all right
so
as we know i is zero so that is why i
less than array.size we have used now in
if condition we'll write a r of i
greater than 0
that is positive number
if the element
here if the element is positive that is
greater than 0 then we'll print
positive number
right now here are
i
so that is how we will print it
now here we'll write else block
and inside the else block
again we will print
negative number
arr of i
okay so after that we have to
increment i plus plus basically
we have to we have to make the loop to
keep on iterating so that is why we have
used i plus plus for the updation like
to move to the next element
in for loop we don't do the updation
part like ourselves but in while loop we
have to do that
now let's try to run this
so here we go
50 to 10 positive numbers
minus 77 negative 82 is positive then
there are negative numbers
so here we have used the while loop
and it is
easy pretty much easy
now
let's move to the next loop which is a
do while loop
the do while loop
the while loop and do while loop are
quite the same kind of loops
the only difference is that the function
is run at least once before the
condition is evaluated in the do while
loop
the while loop on the other hand checks
the condition before executing the
function
so as we can see in the diagram
the do while loop starts and the set of
instructions are executed
after that the while of condition is
checked
if it is true then again the set of
instructions or statement will execute
so basically in do while loop
the set of instruction will execute once
before checking the condition and after
that it will check for the condition to
be true
so we can say the set of instructions
will execute once even if the condition
is not met
let's understand do while loop with the
help of an example here we will do an
example of fibonacci series so fibonacci
series is the series in which the
sum of the
previous two elements is equal to the
third element
so let's start first of all we'll write
function mean
now inside this we will create a
variable let's i this is a counter
variable so we'll start with 1
and now another variable let's say n
let's assign it 10
after that
we'll create a sum variable
and sign it 0
then where
let's say f1
and make it 0
and where f2 and we'll make it
one
all right so we know in
fibonacci sequence first two elements
are 0 and 1
all right so that is why we have
assigned f2 as 1 and we will print it
now we have to do this example with the
help of do while loop so first of all
we'll write do
and inside this do
we'll write i plus plus that is we are
incrementing the counter
then
we'll print
f1 because
in
fibonacci series the first number is
always zero
write f1 we have assigned f1 as zero so
it will get printed
now we'll write sum
equals
f1 plus f2 this is the logic
and after this we'll write f1 equals to
f2 that is we are assigning the value of
f2 to f1
and
f2 equals
sum
so here what we are doing is
for each iteration we are assigning
second number to the first number and
assigning the sum of the last two
numbers to the second number
so
fibonacci sequence works that way
0 1 1
that is the sum of the previous two
elements is the
third element like 0 plus 1 equals to 1
then 1 plus 1 equals to 2 then 2 plus 1
equals to 3 so that is how it goes on
now
after do block we'll use
while loop
inside the while loop
we'll put a condition
that if i is less than equal to n
as we know the value of i is 1 on
increment it become 2 and the value of n
is 10
so the loop so this block will keep on
hydrating till
i becomes equal to 10
and as we know that i is now 2 after
this block executes which is less than
10 so again this block will execute
so it keeps on iterating till n become
till i becomes equal to 10
so it will print up to 10.
that is 0 to
10 digits of fibonacci series
now let's try to run this one
as you can see
these are the fibonacci series 0 1 1 2 3
5 8 13 21 34 there are total 10
digits so as you can see 0 plus 1 equals
to 1
1 plus 2 equals to 3
then there is 3 plus 5 equals to 8
then there is
8 plus 13 equals to 21 13 plus 21 equals
to
34.
so
this is our fibonacci series and we have
done it with the help of two while loop
so these were some examples of loops in
kotlin you can try some more examples on
it it will help you understand this
topic better
kotlin functions
functions in kotlin is very much similar
to functions in java
there are some minor differences in
between them
so let's have a look at them
a kotlin function can be defined as a
block of code which is used to hold the
data
this block of code has a name and is
defined with fun keyword
for example as you can see fun is the
keyword here and info here is the name
of the function
a cortland function divides the program
into small modules
these functions can easily be invoked by
making a call
and to make a call we use the name of
the function with parenthesis
as we can see in the example the
function info is getting invoked from
the main function
that is from the main function we are
making a call to the info function by
using the name of the function with
parenthesis
now
let's understand function parameters
vectors can be defined as the
information that are passed to the
function
so basically functions can accept the
data or information passed to them
these informations and data are passed
in the form of parameters
after receiving the data or information
function can easily use this data to
calculate or display as per the function
definition
the parameters are specified after the
name of the function
and is mentioned inside parentheses
separated by commas
and we can easily pass as much
parameters as we want
for example as you can see
function calc
is accepting three parameters a b and c
of integer type
these three arguments or values are
passed from the main function where the
function call is made
so a b and c three arguments are passed
to the calc function and the function is
providing the average of these three
values
also the values that are passed to the
functions are called arguments and the
parameters are the values that are
defined in the function definition
so now let's understand the next topic
which is function returning values
just like printing the values functions
can also return values
to return a value or values a return
keyword is used
also
while returning a value the return type
of the function is also specified as you
can see in the example
int is the return type of the function
and return keyword is used to return
values to the main function where they
are getting printed
so now moving on to the functions with
no return types
bottling function with no return type
in kotlin language if the function is
not turning anything then we don't need
to specify any return type
but if we want to mention the return
type then we can add unit as the return
type
so basically unit type in kotlin is like
void type in java
that means it is used with function that
doesn't return anything
next is
higher order functions
the higher order function in kotlin is a
function that can accept the functions
as a parameter and can also return a
function
we have heard that function accept
variables but we haven't heard about
function accepting other functions
in higher order function we can easily
do that
so as we can see in the example of
higher order function
the name of the function is high order
and is accepting two integer values that
is num1 and num2 and a function whose
name is fname
now this function fname is accepting two
integer values and its return type is
int
inside the function body we are calling
fname function and printing it
let's understand it with the help of an
example
so this is our kotlin playground
here we'll do an example of higher order
function we'll do a basic example of
higher order function so let's start
first of all we'll create the main
function function main
and inside this main function
let's name the higher order function as
high order
you can name it as per your choice i
have named it high order
and now let's pass the variables let's
say 50
80 and
let's say 40.
now
we have to pass the function to this
higher order function
so
we can do that with the help of these
two column operators and then
the name of the function
let's say the name of the function is my
function
so here we are passing three variables
and a function to the higher order
function
now
we'll create the higher order function
we'll write one keyword
then
hi
order
and now inside the paranthesis we'll
write num1
in the parameters that is 5080 40 we
have to
write the parameters
similarly num3
now after that
here we will
here we are accepting a function as well
so we'll write the name
let's save name of the function is func
name
and
here
int and end the type of the values that
this function will be accepting
here also we have to mention the types
of the function that this function will
be accepting and the return type of the
function as well
so int is the return type of this
function
we'll have to mention that as well
and
by mistake we have done this we have to
use arrow operator for that
and yeah
now we'll write the print basically
we'll call the function
in which
we will define the
definition of this function
so let's say the yeah the function
inverse funct name
and these three are the parameters num1
num2
and num3 we are passing these
arguments
now
let's create this
function definition
so we'll create fun
keyword
my function
function is accepting num1
of integer type
num2 of integer type
and
num3 of integer type
after that
the return type of the function is int
all right
now let's say we want to do the average
of these three numbers
so what we'll do is
write return
num1
plus num2 plus num 3
divided by 3
all right so
all we need to do is just enclose it
within the brackets
yeah
now let's try to run this
as you can see
50 plus 40 90
1980 is equals to 170
170 on
divided by when it is divided by 3 it
will give you 56 56.3
something and as we have used intj value
so it is showing 56 only
so
what we are doing here is first of all
we are calling the high order function
so basically this is a higher order
function and we have named it high order
and we are passing three integer values
and one function
so these three integer values are
passing over here and these are the
parameters and this is how we accept
function as a
parameter this is the syntax of it
after that we are here calling the
definition of this function
so this is the definition we are calling
this function and this is the definition
of this function the value is calculated
over here and then is returned here and
then here it is getting printed
so the answer or the output of this
program is
56
as you can see so this is a higher order
function
now
let's understand lambda function
lambda function
lambda is an abbreviated form of
function writing
the lambda function is written without a
name and is enclosed in curly brackets
the lambda function has the basic syntax
arguments or variables are mentioned on
the left hand side of their operator and
the body of the function is present on
the right hand side of the air operator
in the example
avg is the lambda variable
n1 n2 and n3 on the left side of the
arrow operator are the parameters and on
the right side is the function body
that is the average of three parameters
so as we have understood the lambda
functions and the higher order function
as well now let's understand how to use
higher order function with lambda
function
so lambda function allows us to
eliminate the code and write the code
more compactly
as we can see in this example we have
used the lambda function instead of the
normal function which has decreased the
lines of code
now
let's understand this with the help of
an example
so
this is our example of higher order
function that we have done previously
now we will do this example or edit this
example
with lambda function
so now we'll understand how to use
higher order function and lambda
function together
and it will make our code shorter and
more compact
so as we can see this was the here we
have used two column operators with the
name of the function
now all we need to do
is to create a lambda function over here
and for that as we know that there is no
name for a lambda function
the lambda function is enclosed in two
brackets
now let's say num1
and this is the parameters or the
variables that is on the left hand side
of the arrow operator
then num2
three
after that
here we can see here we have used the
arrow operator now we have moved to the
right hand side of that operator which
is the function body
now we'll use the parentheses
num1
plus num 2
plus num 3 so basically this is the
function body or the function definition
we can say
so now here we have
we are doing the average of these c
numbers as we have done previously
in the higher order function
now here we don't have to use this
function
we can just
eliminate this one
now as we can see our function is almost
done and let's try to run this program
as you can see the output is 56 so here
we have used the lambda function
so this part which is the left hand side
part
of the arrow operator this is the
variables or the values
and this part
on the right hand side is the function
body
so the lambda function is enclosed in
the
in two brackets as we can see here we
have positive three variables and this
is the lambda function
also we have eliminated the my function
function because in that particular
function we are just defining or doing
the
calculation
and that we have already done in this
part so we no longer need that function
so
as you can see this is
here we are using higher order function
with lambda function
so first is what is kotlin
multi-platform
the kotlin multi-platform is a feature
released in 2017 with kotlin 1.2 version
this feature allows us to write the same
code on multiple platforms directly
it focuses on cross-platform app
development
it is based on the idea of write one's
run anywhere approach
but it takes the concept of write once
run anywhere to a much higher level
in which we can write the code once and
target multiple platforms
the kotlin multi-platform
allows you to include other platforms
like linux windows and the web
while its subset that is kotlin
multi-platform mobile
allows the developer to write business
logic code for ios and android from a
single code base
now as we have understood what is caught
in multi-platform now let's understand
how kotlin multi-platform works
so let's take android and ios
the shared business logic code for
android gets converted to java bytecode
that can be executed in jvm
and android has the virtual machine
so it can easily run it
but in case of ios there is no virtual
machine
so the code is converted to the native
code that can be executed on ios
now in kotlin compiler there is a front
end which converts the code into
intermediate representation known as ir
and the backend converts that
intermediate representation to machine
executable code
so in case of android it converts it
into java byte code and for ios it
converts it into ios native machine code
so as we have understood how kotlin
multi-platform works now let's
understand
common portland code
to make common core clean code run
kotlin provides platform specific
compilers
to convert
the code according to different
platforms it provides different
compilers
these platform-specific versions include
kotlin slash jvm
kotlin slash javascript
and kotlin slash native
these versions contain
the platform-specific tools and
libraries and also the extension
to kotlin language
each platform specific version include
various platforms for example
jvm includes java 8
java 6 and android
then the javascript includes browser and
node
the native includes ios mac windows
linux etc
multi-platform libraries helps in
developing shared parts of the project
at one area by providing apis for common
kotlin code and later
share it with all of the target
platforms
the versions of platform specific
libraries provide the libraries that can
be used to increase the platform
specific capabilities of the platforms
that are targeted
now
let's understand the benefits of kotlin
multi-programming
so let's start with the first one which
is
quick and clean code
in cortland multi-platform
we don't have to recreate and rewrite
the code for different platforms
we can simply share the common code
between platforms which saves a huge
amount of time
features like interoperability makes
things very easy and quick as well
also there is no lagging behind the
native platforms and because of that the
developers don't have to wait until the
new features are added for the support
next is
fast development
so as we have already discussed that
code sharing saves a lot of time
and helps in making the development
process much faster and easier
its features including null safety ide
support and interoperability with java
makes it less complex and fast
next is
one language for cross platform and
native apps
most cross platform app development
tools don't allows you to use the
capabilities of native to ios and
android devices
in kotlin we don't need to introduce any
new programming language to the code
base
it is easy to make our android app
work on ios devices without changing
much in code
the major advantage of using kotlin
multi-platform is that we can write the
code once and use it on both mobile
platforms that are android and ios
next is support and community
kotlin is pretty famous in many
companies and organizations
also after google statement of kotlin as
an official language for android
many companies are opting this language
and a huge amount of users
started working on this language
which means there is a huge community
support for the kotlin language
the developers who are already familiar
with java can easily switch to kotlin as
it is fully interoperable with it and
easy to learn
so the java community also adds up to
the kotlins community
now let's have a look at some
applications that are built using kotlin
multi-platform
this includes netflix autodesk vmware
trello
philips
ice rock
so let's start with netflix
netflix the popular ott platform
has rebuilt the current user interface
player in the netflix android
application using kotlin
next is autodesk
autodesk is a multinational software
corporation
kotlin works well with ios and android
without any java native interface
which is a major reason for the company
to opt kotlin multi-platform
next is vmware
vmware is an american cloud computing
and virtualization technology company
the vmware development team wanted a
cross-platform strategy for mobile
applications
then the quarter multi-platform was
selected
and now it is the default go to
framework of choice for vmware
next is trello
trello is a project management
application
the android application of trello is
built using kotlin
relo uses scotland because of its
interoperability with java
next is philips
philips is a popular multinational
corporation and we all have heard about
this company
in philips kotlin multi-platform proved
to be a faster at implementing the new
features and also to get more
interaction in the team between android
and ios developers
the last one is ice rock
its rock is an outsourced company that
provides mobile and backend solutions
for various industries and market
segments
it uses kotlin multiplatform mobile to
create applications for its
clients apart from these there are some
more applications and companies that
have
opted the kotlin multi-platform
what are
threads to understand core routines in
detail
first we will have to understand the
threads
so let's understand it a little
so the programs are just a set of
instructions
when a program runs a process is created
which contains memory process id etc
in that process there are threads
that are used to execute information
every process has at least one thread or
more than one thread
threads
help with the high performance
applications and they work in a
sequential order one after the other
whenever a thread gets stuck while
running an instruction then the other
thread executes the rest of the
instructions
so these were threads
now as we have understood about threads
so let's learn about core routines
coroutines stands for cooperating
functions
the word co stands for cooperation and
routine stands for functions
the core routines can not only do all
the things that a thread can
but is also very efficient
coroutines are lightweight threads that
help to write simplified asynchronous
code that keeps the application
responsive while maintaining heavy tasks
like network
core routines are executed inside the
thread
and are also suspendable
here the word suspendable means we can
execute some instructions and then stop
the core routine in between the
execution and continue when we wish to
and they can also switch between the
threads which gives core routines and
edge over threads
so as we have understood about co
routines so now let's learn about some
features of coroutine
so these are the features of kotlin co
routines
first one is
core routines are lightweight
due to the support for the suspension we
can run many core routines on a single
thread
which doesn't block the thread where the
core routine is running
co routine has a collection of threads
that can be used when required
when the task is done the thread is kept
back to the collection and reused when
need
so this was the first feature
now moving on to the second feature
which is less memory leaks
there are very less memory leaks in
kotlin
because of the structured concurrency
the kotlin coroutines follow the
structured concurrency
this structured concurrency means the
new quarantine can only be launched in a
particular coroutine scope
which sets the lifetime of the core
routine
during the implementation a large number
of coroutines are launched and the
structure concurrency take care of those
so that they are not lost or leaked
this was the second feature
next is built-in cancellation support
cancellation in coroutine is interactive
in order to be cancellable a core
routine must be cooperative
but
if it is not cooperative then it will
wait for the core routine to finish
there are two ways to make a core
routine cancellable
one
through using suspending functions
through cortland dot co routines like
delay function yield function etc
these were cancellable
and second using coroutine scope dot is
active boolean flag
there can be many reasons to cancel a co
routine and also a core routine cannot
be cancelled if it is working in
computation
now moving on to the last feature that
is jetpack integration
there are many libraries of jetpack that
provide support for core routines
for example android ktx is a set of
cortland extensions that provide android
platform and other apis etc
the jetpack is basically a collection of
android development components that
helps in building android apps and
making complex things
simple and easy
these were some features of co-routine
now
let's understand an example of co
routine
but before that we have to understand
some terms of co routines which are
launch delay and run blocking
first is launch
now launch is a core routine builder
launches a new co routine concurrently
that is without blocking the current
thread
it is automatically cancelled when the
resulting job is cancelled
and it doesn't return any result
now next is delay
delay is a suspending function
which is used to suspend a function for
a particular time and resumes it after
that time
it doesn't really block the underlying
thread but allows the other core
routines to run and use the underlying
thread
also it is a cancelable function
then there is run blocking
run blocking is a coroutine builder
again
it basically runs a new core routine and
blocks the current thread until its
completion
or in other words the thread that runs
in it gets blocked for the given
duration until all the code blocks
inside the brackets of run block
complete their execution
now
as you can see in this example
here the run blocking refer to the
thread that runs it
that is the main thread
it is the scope of the core routine
launch
here launch will launch a new core
routine concurrently
then there is delay
delay will suspend the core routine for
a selected time
here that selected time is 2 seconds
by default the time is in milliseconds
now here the word sam will be printed
after
my name is
because of the time delay for 2 seconds
on printing it
it will display my name is sam
let's take this example on kotlin
playground
here it is here we have written that
example here we can see there is a delay
of
2000 l that is 2000 millisecond which is
equal to 2 seconds
so that is why my name is printed
earlier then sam is getting printed
let's run it and let's check the output
as you can see my name is sam is getting
printed because we have delayed this sam
for a like for like two seconds
and now we'll use delay here
okay
let's say three seconds
three thousand milliseconds
which is equal to three seconds
so as you can see there's a delay of two
seconds here is the delay of three
seconds
now what will happen is
will print first after that my name is
printed
as you can see sam my name is
so
i want to show you that how this delay
function work
because here the delay is now three
seconds which is greater than two
seconds that is why my name is getting
printed later
now
moving on to the next topic which is
basics of co routine
so first is scope builder
the core routine scope is used to
declare your own scope
unlike run blocking it just suspends and
releases the threads underlined
it is used to set the scope for new
co-routines
coroutine scope is responsible for
controlling the life cycle of a group of
co-routines and their context
scopes wait for their associated
co-routines to complete before
completing themselves
the core routine builder is an extension
of coroutine scope
now next is explicit job
a job object is returned by launch co
routine builder whose task is to
explicitly wait for the child quality
completion
jobs acts as a handle to the core
routine in the queue
for every co routine that is created it
returns a job instance which identifies
the core routine uniquely and manages
its lifecycle
then there is suspending functions
suspending functions are those functions
that can be paused and then continued
later
they can be used inside the co-routines
and can use other suspending functions
as well
they are used for long-running
operations and wait for it to complete
without blocking
the syntax of suspending functions is
same as that of the normal function
but with the addition of suspended
keyword
so these were some basics of coroutine
so what is kotlin jetpack compose
the jetpack compose is a modern user
interface development toolkit
it makes the app development process
easy and speeds it up
because of the jetpack compose you can
write less code as compared to the
current view building approach
which also leads to less potential bugs
it's changed the way developers create
user interface making it easier and
faster to write and more performant to
run
before the jetpack compose
xml layouts were used to make native
user interface
the jetpack compose is much better
advanced and easier than xml
with the help of
jetpack compose we can make a more
declarative user interface with less
code
so
as we have understood the kotlin jetpack
compose
so now let's have a look at why we need
or use the jetpack compose
so why jetpack compose the jetpack
compose is used because it has huge
benefits over the previous user
interface building system
first it accelerates the development
there are various features in compose
that helps in doing the task faster
for example previews
by making multiple previews we can save
a lot of time that we earlier wasted in
checking the user interface component in
different states
but with the help of multiple previews
we can easily do that
also the compose is compatible with
existing code
many libraries like kotlin co routines
view model etc work just fine with
compose
second is independent
the library of compose is not integrated
with any operating system
which means it is easy to add the new
features to the user interface without
changing the operating system
now next is intuitive
in compose the apis that are used is
intuitive and declarative
intuitive means easy to understand and
declarative means
all we need to do is to describe the
user interface and the rest will be
taken care of by compose
the components that are made with the
compose are not confined to a specific
activity
which makes the component easy to reuse
worth is powerful and feature loaded
compose is a powerful and feature loaded
that helps in making the app attractive
and user friendly you can make the app
as you desired with these animations
which are quite easy to implement
compose has the support for dark theme
material design animations etc which
makes things very easy for the
development
now
how does compose work
the word compose came from composite
which means the collection of objects
the compose jetpack
works on a composite design pattern
this pattern is used while dealing with
hierarchical data
like parent child relationship
so in compose every view can contain
one or more child views within it
and the child views can further have
sub-child views
unlike previous approaches where we
cannot introduce additional
functionalities in a view
now
as we have understood about this topic
now we will move on to the next topic
which is composable function
a composable function is just like any
other normal function of kotlin
but the only difference is
it is annotated by the composable sign
it helps in transforming the data to the
user interface hierarchy
all the functions with composable sign
indicate that this function is the
compose function and the sign tells the
compose compiler that this function is
intended to convert data into user
interface and they can only be called
from other composible functions
the composable function doesn't return
any values like the codeline function
but instead
emit user interface elements to the
compose runtime system for rendering as
we can see in this example
composable annotation is used to make
the function message a composable
function
the element text is also a composable
function which comes from compose
library
with the preview annotation as we can
see we are able to see how our ui that
is user interface is going to look like
the preview are often written with
composable annotation
and multiple previews can be added to
the composable function having different
parameters
now
the output of this example would be
hello rahul
so now moving on to the next topic which
is layout
the layout allows us to arrange the
components in such a way so that they
don't overlap each other
it basically arranges the components in
a proper manner otherwise they got
staggered over each other
it is one of the most important
component that helps in creating user
interface
it helps in alignment and arrangement
purposes for the user interface
a out is a compose function which allows
us to arrange elements in a row column
and box
so let's understand
here we can see in this example
there is a row keyword which means these
three words hello there mate that are
written inside the row function will be
arranged horizontally
the row function allows us to arrange
the elements in a horizontal manner
so hello there and mate will be arranged
horizontally
similarly the column function
let's arrange the elements in a vertical
manner
so in this case that is in the case of
column function
hello there meet
will be arranged vertically
so this was example of layout now moving
on to the next topic which is
box
in box layout the children
are stacked over each other by default
so we have to align them to put them in
different positions or proper positions
we use the align modifier to set the
position or alignment for children
elements
as we can see in this example we have
used a line modifier and we can also see
there is alignment dot top center and
alignment dot bottom center
these are the alignment options that are
applied to the child user interface
there are total nine alignment options
let's have a look at them
first three are
alignment.topstart
alignment.top and
alignment.top center
here
alignment.topstart will align the user
interface to the top left corner
top end will align at the top right
corner
and top center will align at top center
position next three are alignment dot
center start alignment dot center end
and alignment dot center
here center start will align the user
interface to the mid left
corner center end will align at mid
right corner and center will be aligned
at the mid center position in between
center start and center end
x3
dot bottom start alignment dot bottom
end and alignment dot bottom center
here
bottom start will align the user
interface to the bottom left corner
bottom end will align at the bottom
right corner and bottom center will be
aligned at the bottom center position
that is in between bottom start and
bottom end
so these were the nine possible
alignments
now
coming to material design
as the name suggests it helps to improve
the appearance using the material design
styling
there are three pillars of material
design which are color
typography shape
first is
color
by using values from wrapped theme you
can easily color wherever it is needed
inside the compose graphic package there
is a color class which is used by
jetpack compose
to define material design color system
color class is used
there are 13 attributes that can be used
and those are
primary primary variant secondary
secondary variant
background surface error
on primary on secondary on background on
surface on error
and is light
each of them having different means and
is used to color wherever it is needed
then there is typography
in the material theme there are material
typography styles which are used to
style or define a type system
with the help of typograph class we can
customize font style font weight font
family letter spacing text decoration
and many more attributes
third is shape
material design allows us to define
shape for small medium and large
components as well
just like typography we can easily
create shapes
now coming to next topic which is list
and animations
the list and animations are one of the
most important thing for building an app
we have already discussed row and column
earlier
here we will discuss about lazy
composibles
laser composables include lazy row and
lazy column the lazy row makes a
horizontal scrolling list
and the lazy column makes the vertical
scrolling list
in this example lazy column is used
as we can see
here lazy columns is used
that is vertical scrolling list
and this is how we add elements or items
here we are adding a single item and
here we are adding multiple items
with items there is an integer 7 which
means 7 items can be added
now
just like list
animations are also very important for a
smooth and attractive user experience
there are various apis that can give you
control and help with the animation
they are
animation visibility
it is used if you are animating
appearance and disappearance
then there is animation
it is used if you want to have fine
control over animation time
then there is crossfade
it is used to switch between composables
with a crossfade animation then there is
remember infinite transition
if the animation is state-based and
happens during composition and is
infinite then this is used
next is
update transition
it is used if you are animating multiple
values simultaneously
so these were some apis that can give
you control over the animations
and with that we have come to the end of
this video
i hope it helped you all in
understanding the concepts of kotlin
thank you so much for being here stay
safe and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you